hello folks welcome to
rational science and uh
today we're going to be talking about
the neutrino
uh or as the italians i guess would call
a piccolino
neutron in fact it was named by the
italians
and uh before we can get a handle on the
neutrino we need to get
uh some foundations and there's at least
two of them i want you to be aware of
today one of them
is the notion of the word field what is
a field
and the other one is one we talked about
last week which is mass
okay what is mass uh i better just said
what the hell is mass that's a better
way to put it yet okay
okay so let's start uh with this this
was the original
planetary atom of the first uh couple
decades of the 20th century okay
that's been modified quite a bit here's
the you could say the modern version
okay i'll put it here side by
side okay now i want you to understand
that
um that picture on the right
is a little misleading okay and by the
end of the day by the end of today's
lecture you should be able to tell
me why why it's misleading okay
should be able to tell me why that
picture of all those particles inside
the nucleus
is misleading okay that's essentially
what what the lecture today is about
okay
here we have uh all these particles that
are allegedly
inside the atom their sub atomic
particles okay
and we start out with a standard proton
and neutron everybody learns that in
high school
but then it gets a little more
complicated okay
we have the up quark down quart charm
top strange bottom we got all these
things that they found out there
we have pions muons electrons the taus
we have the gluons of w bosons the z
boson and we should not forget you know
the mass particle the particle of mass
the higgs
the graviton obviously they're still
looking for that one photons are
buzzing around neutrino which is the one
we're going to talk about today
and then you have all these other
particles or semi-quasi particles or
semi-particles or whatever particles
that they've been vented for just about
everything we have the solar tone we
have the
phonon the particle of sound we have the
tachyon one that travels faster than
light we have the kronon the particle of
time
[Laughter]
and so on you know we've got all kinds
of particles out there
and uh yeah it makes you kind of wonder
right uh
and that's not enough uh there's another
issue there's another level
of complexity that you have to add to
that and here it is
the fact that you have uh anti-particles
for example this is the
hydrogen compared to the antihydrogen
one has an electron which is negative
the other guy has a positron which is
positive and the proton is the anti uh
is the opposite of the antiproton and so
on and you have anti particles for every
particle out there okay
and you say is is this kind of crazy now
are we going nuts here with so many
particles
let me tell you where the problem is the
problem is that quantum
field theory field right
says that every particle is a vibrating
field that's what it really is and
that's also what string theory says
essentially they say look
there's this line that's vibrating and
that's your graviton and for sure
they'll extend it to every particle
in quantum to the electron to the proton
to the neutron that extent say oh what's
the new tensor vibrating part
uh vibrating line so all of these are
vibrating fields lines whatever you want
to think about them
okay so let me show you a little bit of
what the problem
problem i see okay with that okay let's
go with the first one here
first we go with the uh background
radiation okay
cosmic background radiation and you can
say that this is the uh
the field of temperature okay so we have
a temperature field okay okay let's uh
make this a little more complex let's
add the gravity field because you know
you have space time
and space time is uh is made out of a
field right
it's uh what is space-time space-time is
some kind of vibrating field as well
okay so we have to put the gravity field
okay which is what whatever space time
is
okay but on that we have to superimpose
now the electric
field you know like if you have
electricity in your house
well that's not the same as gravity okay
so uh
you have to add these these fields one
right on top of the other
okay they they kind of superimpose
okay and we don't stop there obviously
here we have the magnetic field okay you
know what a magnetic field is it's what
keeps two magnets together right
okay so now we add the magnetic field to
these fields we're going to superimpose
all these fields okay
and we don't stop there we have the
higgs field which we talked about the
other day let's assume this is the higgs
field
okay and so uh you can see it's getting
quite complex there
okay uh and now the one we're gonna talk
about today the
neutrino field again let's assume this
is the neutrino field okay so
we're gonna add this one to the pile and
you can see what's happening here all
these
fields are kind of superimposing okay
and of course we got to think about the
electromagnetic field and i mean
light because light is not exactly
magnetism and light is not exactly
electricity
so even though one is the electric field
the other one is the um
magnetic field the electromagnetic field
which underlies
um light the waves of light well they're
a little different than uh
electricity and magnetism so we have to
keep those
as separate fields and then of course
you've got uh for example here's the uh
i'm going to illustrate this as the pion
field because you know you have pions
out there
okay and so you can see on the right how
complicated this is getting
uh here's the muon field because pions
decay into uh
muons okay so we're gonna add that one
in on the pile
and so the question is uh you know what
do we have in the end well we have a
bunch of fields
and here you know assuming this is what
a field looks like
a three-dimensional notion of a field
whatever that is
it's uh some kind of a fishnet okay it's
uh
i don't know you can say it's um it's a
trampoline
it's a canvas you know they have all
these synonyms for that but what you're
staring at essentially is some kind of
fishnet
and the question is whether this fishnet
is for real okay
is it for real or are we talking about
what what is this thing
and so we have one issue here the first
issue and the first issue is that people
always ask for example in the case of
the rope model how is it that all these
ropes
why can't i see them why can't i touch
them how do they avoid tangling
be nice if these people would go first
to quantum mechanics the quantum field
theory
and ask them well you have all these
fishnets out there three dimensional
fishnets or maybe four dimensional
fishnets
how do they avoid tangling you know i
mean here you have
and they're all different fields by the
way okay keep that in mind they're all
different fields
you have the neutrino feel the muon
field the electric field magnetic field
you have all these fields out there and
they're superimposing out there in space
all around us
how do they avoid tangling how can we
distinguish one from the other
see when they talk about fields they
usually talk about one
one of them at a time they'll talk about
the gravity field or
the gravitational field or or they'll
talk about the electricity
the electric field for example but they
never talk about them all together
because then people might wonder hey how
do all these fields you know avoid
tangling
so that's the first question people
should uh answer before they ask me to
answer how do the ropes avoid tangling
okay
how's that for a deal okay that's the
first issue we've got all these fields
superimposed upon each other one of
those
is going to be the neutrino field okay
how about mass what do we have with mass
well uh i'm going to start with some of
the comments that people made because
there were lots of several comments on
the issue of mass people
are concerned about you know what really
is this mass thing so they have
questions about it
and i discussed that last week came from
that lecture okay here's one file he
says
i thought mass was volume times density
okay seems straight forward yeah it is
but
uh if you look at the chart there you'll
see that density is equal to mass
divided by volume and volume is equal to
mass divided by density
so what have we learned well we learned
that uh these are calculations these are
these are not definitions we don't know
what mass is we don't know what density
is we don't know what volume is what we
know is how to calculate them based on
these
relations okay so uh yeah people say you
know what is mass
and they give you an equation and they
say that's the definition
no that's not a definition that's how to
calculate
density okay density you can look it up
in the dictionary and give you a
definition
okay of what density is and the question
is whether you want to accept that
definition especially if it's just a
circular if it's a
talcology like you know density relates
the volume volume relates the mass mass
delays the density and l all of them
relate to each other
so all you have is a circular argument
all you have is a bunch of concepts
okay so this is the issue you have to be
careful about
definitions definitions have to be
independent of anything else
in the sense that you don't you don't
chase your tail around with definitions
by putting synonyms or whatever that's
not a definition
and again you know to say uh mass is
equal to
volume density times density all you're
saying is
how to calculate mass okay so that's the
first issue that's not a definition of
what mass
is we don't have a definition of mass
today as i
discussed the other day okay here's
another issue that someone
raised uh regarding mass regarding uh
the lecture i gave the other day
the photon is massless another theory is
proposing that the mass
equal to zero is the result of plus m
plus minus
m following the same idea of e equals e
minus plus
e plus however what does mean uh
negative mass negative kilogram good
question you know all they're doing is
uh
doing accounting putting pluses and
minuses in front
of an undefined concept called energy
and so
again for calculation purposes they can
do all that stuff what does it have to
do with physics is the question
because unless we see a physical object
in there we cannot give a physical
interpretation to that equation
and that's where we stand today okay so
another fella you know says
exactly or more or less the opposite or
he he kind of came in around the same
lines actually and he says the following
he says um
he says when a photon carries an image
of a star does its mass
increase so it can't be zero so how does
the photon travel at c
in other words uh he's right he's saying
look you know
these people are saying that um
the photon is massless okay but that's
the rest
mass of the photon they clarify that you
see what do you mean rust mass i mean
are we talking about how many
uh components it has like what it's made
out of
like 10 10 whatever 10 units of mass
that is that what the
rest mass means you know the rest mass
of i don't know an elephant is
1 billion units of mass whatever those
units are irrespective right we have
a billion units of mass is that what
rest mass of the elephant means
because when we put the uh elephant in
motion no longer are we talking about
what it's made of
now we're talking about how much
pressure or how much inertia
it causes out there in some kind of
interaction
we're no longer talking about how much
how many
atoms or whatever it's made of units of
mass it's made of
and again we have that problem are we
talking about quantity of matter of an
object or are we talking about some
acceleration
and the inertia or pressure or whatever
it causes or resistance etc
this is where the question is okay what
is mass
what notion do we have for mass and
fortunately the
the wikipedia says we have seven
different notions of mass
love it you know it's great you know
okay another fellow asked this question
he says does the rope have weight okay
and uh here i can show you
uh whether why uh it doesn't have
so-called weight or mass okay because
it's the mediator between
two atoms and here's a pictorial version
of that
okay what you see there is a mountain
climber okay
and what are we saying here we're saying
that uh you know the the mountain
climber essentially feels the other
mountain climber that's hanging from him
he doesn't really feel the rope that's
connecting both of them
okay so so uh we have to distinguish the
mediator
of light which you see at the bottom
from the atoms what we what we call mass
usually is anything made out of atoms
not the rope that interconnects them
it's like we can't feel that rope or the
atoms can't feel that rope because the
atom can only feel the other atom at the
other end it's like the mountain climber
holding on to the other mountain climber
they don't feel the robe even though the
rope
does have is obviously some weight
and the question is you know can we get
there and take the rope away from
between two atoms and weigh it and
calculate its mass or whatever well you
know have fun with that one
okay so uh all i can tell you is it's
the mediator and as the mediator all
we're looking at is
the mass at the other end which in this
case is the other atom
then you can talk about mass because
mass is always related to
atoms it's a it's something of this
world something in in our
current world that uh in our macro world
that we deal with uh when we talk about
mass
okay here's uh another issue this guy
uh gave me a hammer over the head okay
let me get this guy out here give me a
second here
okay and he says uh the hammer and the
feather have different mass but has the
same weight i said that okay
and he said nobody says that billy
nobody you don't even understand the
mainstream view of weight versus math
well um the mainstream doesn't have
a uh a definition of mass
first of all second you know you can see
this fellow he did not say
see you're wrong bill uh that's not mass
you don't have the right notion
okay what is the correct notion see he
didn't put the correct notion
and nobody will nobody will because they
know they're gonna be in trouble as soon
as they put something down
it's easy to tear apart whatever
whatever they put down
we don't have a definition of the word
mass and that's why you know i'd like to
always bring up mr wheeler mr taylor and
they said
very clearly they said you know there's
uh
if you think that mass is quantity of
matter okay
that number does not equal mass okay so
this is the first
lesson you gotta learn okay you can't
you can't
keep saying that mass is the quantity of
matter because you here you have
high level people you know uh
specialists uh phd's in so-called
mathematical physics
and they're telling you in your face
that mass is not the quantity of matter
okay so please get that under your belt
and if it's not the quantity of matter
what the hell is mass
that's the question for you to answer
what is mass
why is this important well um because we
need to figure out what mass is
i mean there is obviously something
called mass and we use
the word mass when we put it in newton's
equation
famous newton's equation mass mass
divided by distance squared
that's what we use we use that to send
rockets to the moon we use it to
calculate
the gravitational constant g uh
and it's empirically certified you know
we deal with this
every day mass mass divided by distance
squared
and so we do use the word mass but see
those two masses that we put in there
they are weight they're not mass we call
it mass
insinuate that it's quantity of matter
but how do we calculate those two masses
well we calculated by weighing them
and we say so many kilograms of mass and
that's the number we're going to put in
the equation
so what we're putting there is weight
we're putting
how much pressure that entered that
thing that you put there
how much pressure that object that mass
had on the scale
that that's what that's the number
you're putting that's the kilograms
you're putting in there
kilograms is not a measure of how many
atoms
how many units of mass no kilogram is a
measure of
weight it's not but it is it's what we
use every day we say
weigh it and then you'll know how how
much mass it has
do you know how much mass it has no you
know it has
more mass than this and less mass than
that other thing and what do we mean by
that we mean that we have a standard
which we call the kilogram and we
measure everything against that kilogram
and then say well this is the kilogram
anything that weighs more is greater
than one kilogram anyways thing that
weighs less is
less than one kilogram what is it weight
we always talk about weight
and then we have this very vague
definition saying quantity of matter
which these people
uh we learned taylor tell you it's not
mass and it turns out that this is not
the notion
of mass that quantum mechanics uses the
quantity of matter
they use the same thing as the
relativistic mass the special
relativistic mass
accelerate the thing and its mass
increases
are we saying that it put more kilograms
in it like
did it did the elephant eat more grass
or whatever is that how
he became bigger he put more atoms
inside his body is that what we mean
when
we accelerate the elephant almost the
speed of light and now
his mass increased no we're talking
about
pressure we're talking about
acceleration we're talking about
resistance we're talking about a lot of
stuff
except quantity of matter okay
so it's important to understand that
it's this duality
that comes in very handy especially when
we get to the neutrino
okay keep this in mind okay okay so
here's um
here's a feather and um hammer
experiment
it was done on the moon for those who
view who believe that we went to the
moon
if you don't believe that we went to the
moon because maybe you're a flat earther
or whatever no problem at the bottom you
see it done here on earth
okay the feather on the left and the
little metal
you can call that the hammer doesn't
matter and they fall at the same time
because they remove the air from that
container
on the right you have the actual motion
with air in it
okay so that's the comparison you can
see what happens okay so essentially
if we remove the air okay the the
feather
and whatever you want hammer elephant
fall at the same time towards the center
of the earth
okay so that means that if we're in
outer space
you know and we see this for example let
me show you
we see an elephant and a hammer they
fall at the same time
because in outer space there's no air
we're gonna assume there's no air all
the way to the
to the surface of the earth so they
would fall together at the
surface of the earth in fact it probably
would fall together anyways because
there's going to be very little
resistance of air to either one of these
um objects okay so you won't see any
difference anyways
fine but
let's uh let's do something drastic
let's remove the earth
okay well
no let's let's do it take a step in
between we're going to put the elephant
against the hammer but this time we're
gonna put him on a seesaw some kind of
scale
and of course the elephant's gonna beat
the hammer
it's gonna weigh more than the hammer
and you say hold it in the previous case
they both fell at the same time towards
the earth
here the elephant seems to weigh more
than a hammer
you know like let me compare them again
here's uh here's the elephant falling
with uh
let me get put this in here here's they
are in free fall
there's nothing below them and so they
fall at the same time
but when we put them on the scale the
elephant beats the uh hammer
and you say well what's going on here i
mean i thought they weighed the same out
there in space and
here we can tell the difference that you
know between the weight of the elephant
and the weight of the hammer
or you could say the mass of the
elephant and the mass of the
of the hammer right now we can't tell
the difference and yeah weight is equal
to the gravitational uh acceleration
uh on the mass okay but what are we
comparing here we're comparing not the
elephant against the earth like we did
here see in this case
here we're essentially comparing each
one individually against the earth
okay but when we put them against the
scale we're comparing them one against
the other
and here the issue is you know in the
case of the rope model very simple is
how many ropes
are attached from each one of these
objects to the earth and you have more
atoms on the elephant than you have from
the hammer and that's why the elephant
pushes the his side of the sea saw down
compared to the earth
the hammer okay but now again uh let me
remove the earth okay and now we can't
tell the difference between the uh
elephant and the hammer okay in fact uh
we can remove the seesaw as well because
it plays no role okay and so this is
what we would see if they're in
completely outer space out there in the
middle of nowhere with no object
you know in the middle of two galaxies
for example
okay just in the middle of nowhere well
then you couldn't tell which one has
more mass and which one has
uh less mass or more weight and less
weight because right now you can't tell
the difference the only way you could
tell the difference there
is if you compare them and you have
nothing to compare them against
okay so only under the rope model can
you tell
why the elephant falls faster
against the seesaw okay than the hammer
okay because one has more ropes attached
to the earth than the other one
right and again it's a question of
quantity of matter
okay so so this this is what i'm trying
to get to okay it's quantity of matter
that is the definition of mass but it
gets in the way
of uh quantum mechanics and and
relativity for that matter
and in the case of quantum mechanics
it's going to be a serious problem for
the
tiny neutrino okay because the neutrino
what are we going to talk about we're
going to say that
what is the quantity of matter of a
neutrino
are we saying that neutrinos made of all
these little tiny
sub neutrino particles uh you know
mariology what is it made out of and it
turns out that neutrino is one of those
elementary fundamental particles so it's
not made of anything
according to you know the wizards of
quantum mechanics
so it's not made of anything if it's not
made of anything what do you mean the
mass
of the neutrino well again it's one of
those things when
you have to accelerate it and when you
accelerate it suddenly
you're talking about mass but are you
talking about mass or are you talking
about
energy using einstein's equation where
you say well
how much energy do you need to get that
thing accelerated
or how much energy is in the process
of getting this neutrino to move and now
you take that energy
equal to mc squared and you say what's
equal to mass times velocity of light
squared
and now you can calculate the mass
because you can say okay mass is equal
to energy divided by velocity of light
squared very simple
you know um equation and that's what
they do so they calculate the mass
not based on how many atoms or how many
units of mass it's made out of
you know the rest mass now they
calculated based on dividing how much
energy they sensed or detected in the
system
whether it received energy or uh
expelled energy whichever
right they look at that energy they
measure that they say okay let's convert
it into
mass through e equals mc squared
actually mass equals energy divided by
c squared so they're going to calculate
the mass based on energy because energy
is something they say they can control
they say oh we know how much energy it
took to
accelerate a proton or a neutron or
whatever
okay so that's something they they have
in their uh
machines i know because you know i work
with accelerators uh they were called
implanters i didn't work at the giga or
mega i worked at the kilo electron vote
okay i was a little more modest
but uh that's what it is you're
accelerating something and then so you
say well i know how much energy i need
to accelerate that
and then you take then you want to
calculate the mass of what you
accelerated and you just divide
energy kilo electron votes in my case
divided by the velocity of light squared
that's how it's done okay that's in
semiconductor processing
okay so um so what's the deal here
well um we have to get to why did we
need
this neutrino where did that come from i
mean wasn't it simple just to say
the atom is equal to the neutron
assuming you know
greater than hydrogen deuterium and
upwards right uh
neutron proton and electron we're done
it's simple
universe don't don't mess with it right
they couldn't do that because they found
out that there were some elements
okay that spontaneously decayed
morphed uh transmuted
whatever you want to call it they
changed
into another element okay so you take
your
famous case is carbon-14 given 5000
years or so you know it
it morphs into sodium okay and
uh yeah sodium magnesium no i'm sorry
into nitrogen what am i saying carbon
turns into nitrogen
carbon 14 into nitrogen 14. and that's
how they calculate you know the um
the age of bones like if you take a
neanderthal bone it can only go so far
maybe 50 000 60 000 years into the past
and you can see how much carbon has
transmuted
converted morphed into nitrogen
14 and that gives you a measure of how
much time has passed
from the time that bone began to you
know lose its uh
it decayed it will call it a beta
decayed okay
how much time since it for the process
of beta decay to take place okay because
they've got that down pat they know
exactly how much time it takes for
carbon to morph into
into nitrogen okay okay so uh
here we have a beta decay typical uh
reaction using a final diagram
okay and what are we talking about here
let me get this here
um you have a neutron what is a neutron
well a neutron it has an up quark
and two down quarks okay and bear with
me for a second i'll go over that in a
second but
just bear with me for now we have these
three quarks okay three quarters for
master mark yeah that's where they got
this
you say well is it that they discovered
the quarks out there no no it was an
accounting procedure
that's what i'm going to go over in a
second but just look at the
reaction here of what happens here so
that you understand the process where
they got the neutrino okay
and so you have the neutron which is a
different animal than
neutrino okay neutron is a sort of like
a big ball inside the nucleus neutrino
is something else
a tiny particle apparently that flies
off during a reaction
so the neutron is going to turn into a
proton which is what happens like in the
case
of uh carbon-14s and all these and uh
some of them are
negative beta decays others are positive
so that's a little more complex
let's just go with a simple case here we
have a neutron it's going to convert
into a proton and in order to do that
one of the down quarks
it's got one up quark two down quarks
one of those down parts is going to turn
into an up
quark so we go from one up two down
to two ups one down okay that's what's
gonna happen in this conversion is this
this transmutation in this morphing
metamorphosis okay but there's a
reaction that happens right before that
and that's that you have the um the weak
boson a negative weak negative boson
okay
comes out of there and from there that
one
suffers a separate reaction which is a
separation of
an electron and what they're going to
call an anti-neutrino
okay and the reason they needed that uh
neutrino is that they had an accounting
problem they had some energy in there
that they couldn't account for
and so they said well what is that and
they had different ideas and finally uh
the one that triumph was the fact that
or the notion that there was an extra
particle in there
okay so they have this extra particle
and they say okay we'll get the neutrino
and now we can explain
you know what's happening here and
here's the um let me show you the um
the reaction how it works for beta decay
and again this is just a beta minus dk
okay
just so you get an a well we have both
there really uh
you have the up quark first we look at
charge we're going to look at charging
we're going to look at mass
first let's look at charts that had to
be an accounting procedure that matched
out because you have to have this
conservation of energy issue you know
second law of thermodynamics
and that was well grounded you could not
escape that you cannot say well i'm
going to violate the law of second
uh the law of conservation of energy the
second law of thermodynamics now you
can't because everybody believed in that
and they said well i can't
i got to stay within those bounds and
the way they stayed is okay let's look
at charge
charges as the up quark has two thirds
uh
charge and you say is that what really
it has in there no no this is an
accounting procedure
they had to create the quarks out of
nowhere because they have to explain
this what they had to explain
is how a proton and a neutron are made
of quarks but one has charge and the
other one doesn't
and so they say okay this is simple you
know the proton has two-thirds
the charge two-thirds charge that's
four-thirds charge
that's over one right then you subtract
the one-third
electron charge the one from the
electron and um
and then you get three thirds which is
one and that gives you the same
um uh charge as the
the electron okay one electron has
charge one and so does the proton
okay how do you do it for the neutron
well the neutron is in reverse more or
less
you have remember you have the the down
quarks okay and so you have
two thirds from the up quark one upward
and two negative
one thirds which is the down quark you
have two-thirds minus
two-thirds you get zero and so now the
accounting process for
neutrons and protons based on the notion
of quarks matched
they say hey we got a solution to to why
neutrons have
no charge and protons have charge it's
based on this down
and up quark you know in the case of the
proton it's uh two ups one down
that gives you one uh charge which is
the charge of the electron
and positive charge of the proton and in
the case of the neutron you have um
you know you have to explain why it
ended up with zero and you have yeah
it's got one
up two thirds minus two one thirds which
is the down quark it has two down quarks
you get zero
so the charge was matched they say okay
we're done with that one
how about mass well mass was a problem
because you could just have neutrons
protons and
uh electrons there was some other factor
in there that they couldn't account for
and so that's when they created the
neutrino they say oh the neutrino
they created a new particle did they see
the part they touched the particle no no
it was an accounting procedure they
needed to put a particle in there just
like
dark matter no different they can't
explain what's going on out there they
say well there's got to be another mass
that's
pulling on the stars on the outside of a
galaxy
we can't see it okay we'll call it dark
matter i call it dark kilograms because
they just put them in by hand they said
let's put more kilograms out there
we sprinkle it sprinkle it on the
outside of a galaxy and that
that imitates simulates with our
computers right
what we observe and that's how dark
matter came into being this is no
different
absolutely no different they said look
how do we explain proton and neutron
charge well we explain it with uh these
quarks we're just going to invent the
course we're going to give these guys
two-thirds this guy
minus one-third what did they do with
mass they said well what do we do with
mass now
there's there's an extra mass and an
extra energy in there we can't account
for
and so they said we're going to invent
the anti-neutrino and a neutrino so they
created this neutrino
okay so now they could explain uh beta
minus and beta plus dks
okay that's what they did they simply
created these particles out of nowhere
not because mother nature has them out
there but it's because it's an
accounting procedure we need to get the
numbers right
and we need to get the conservation of
energy right okay
keep this in mind this is where this is
how this developed okay
okay um
so let's continue here this is when
all these people began searching for
this neutrino says well does the
neutrino exist or is it just a
fiction of mathematics i mean are these
people just creating
stuff to make the accounting go right so
guess what they had to find a neutrino
or
else they would have had serious
insurmountable problems in quantum
mechanics okay
and so they started giving out nobel
prizes handing them out in 1956
common marines ranks i think it's his
name
detected anti-neutrinos for the first
time
and they didn't get their noble until uh
what was it until 1995 they had to wait
almost 40 years
one of them because the other guy died
in the meantime colin died uh before
that so he didn't get the noble
i guess he's got in his tombstone should
have received a noble or so
1988 first noble given to the neutrino
guys uh
for what for the neutrino beam method
and the demonstration of the doublet
structure of the leptons through the
discovery of the muon neutrino
okay and they kept giving more prizes in
2002 they remember the neutrino guys
again they said
look for pioneering contributions to
astrophysics
in particular for the detection of
cosmic neutrinos so now we saw cosmic
neutrinos i'm out there in the sun you
know
and just uh five years ago they gave it
for the discovery neutrino oscillations
which shows do neutrinos have mass
they had to show that the neutrinos have
mass because
otherwise if you don't have a master
then what's the point of the neutrino
and they had a problem of detecting the
neutrino because they
the way they put it is that they said it
interacts weakly with matter
whatever that means means that i mean
does it interact or doesn't it
and so the the neutrino
neutrino neutral means it's got no
charge
zero charge okay that help that solve
that problem but then
does it have zero mass if it has zero
mass and what's the point of the
neutrino
i mean you have this energy in there it
doesn't match you need more energy and
the neutrino
kind of comes in there with the extra
energy that you need
but energy is equal to mass so you
better find the mass of the
neutrino so they had to figure out how
to
how to create mass for the neutrino at
all costs
it had to be it it it must be otherwise
you know we have a big problem because
we cannot explain something as
simple as beta decay or transmutation of
proton into neutron neutron into proton
that was the issue
so so the key the key little thing was
there that was this neutrino
the piccolino neutron okay
and guess what yeah they finally
detected in here's uh
here's uh the one in 1970 they
finally were able to see it detect it
whatever
in a hydrogen bubble chamber okay and
you can see it's one of those uh
uh you can read it there that line there
they think those are traces all those
squiggly lines that you see there or any
line that you see in there
they think are traces of particles so
they go in there and they say okay this
one's johnny this one's tommy and this
one's the neutrino
that's how they do it okay and the
question is whether
you know can you take a photograph of
motion
because if that's a trace quite a long
trace you know you got
some amount of time there is this just a
simulation a computer simulation
is that how they come up with these they
think this is what's happening in there
because the particles supposedly go
through hydrogen you got hydrogen gas in
there
and supposedly the the particle whizzes
through the gas
pushing all the you know all the gas
molecules sideways
as it goes through and that's what they
think those traces are
they think they are the itinerary of
some particle that just
plowed through the hydrogen atoms the
hydrogen molecules
essentially okay and so that's the first
issue can you take a picture of motion
or are these contrails is that what what
these pictures are
that's what they think they are okay but
here's the punch line for today
and this is the one you should be able
to answer on the test
okay this is important so pay attention
okay
turns out that um you say well okay so
neutrino is in there it's part of the
atom as i showed at the beginning of the
lecture
uh no uh there's another process going
on
that you should be very much aware of
okay and it's a
it's called the hocus pocus process okay
that's why it's called
quantum magic here's your magic okay
and this comes from authoritative
sources uh fermilab slack stanford
linear accelerator
okay they publish a magazine called
symmetry they publish their stuff there
says
the collisions that create both pairs of
top quarks okay
and single tops okay borrow energy from
where virtual particles they get it from
the virtual
particle okay what is this virtual
particle i never heard of that one okay
what is that
virtual particles wink in and out of
existence
for only brief moments but they affect
interaction between particles around
them
they come into existence for a moment i
guess to make the equation come out
right i guess uh conservation of energy
i don't know okay let's find out the
more massive a particle
the more infrequently it appears as a
virtual particle
okay an interaction needs a very large
virtual particle
to create a heavy top quark okay
remember the top quark weighs more than
the neutron that contains it which
weighs more than the uh gold atom that
contains
all both of them so you figure that one
out
physics is cannot predict the emergence
of a virtual particle
by the energy of the machine so you have
this machine you have this accelerator
okay and that's not what's going to tell
you anything
about where this energy came from
because it's
energy outside the system there's a
reaction
and they say well where did the energy
come from oh you know
it came from the vacuum i thought vacuum
was nothing
i don't know you're wrong bro vacuum is
a bunch of particles
which one do you want which field do you
want we have the muon field the pioneer
we have the electro
electric field the magnetic field we
have all these fields we even have the
gravitational field in there the higgs
field
there are all these fields there and
whenever there's a reaction here
they borrow one of these vibrating
fields from the vacuum
momentarily split second you're talking
about migrants of a second
uh you know very small portions of a
second borrows that energy to do the
reaction to fool us to fool all the
particle uh
mathematicians and then it goes back to
being part of space again
vacuum you know this seizing energy
that's all around us
so so we got a little problem here
because the way they've created this
energy
needed to for to for the accounting
of their equation you know first to say
proton is equal to
uh neutron minus electron and
anti-neutrino
the way they do that they borrow this
anti-neutrino they borrow it not from
the atom it wasn't in the atom it wasn't
in the neutron it wasn't
in the proton or the electron for that
matter no it's borrowed
from virtual particles virtual particles
meaning particles that come in from the
void
because the void is made of particles so
they borrow that energy
that particle whatever from the vacuum
and then they give it back and that's
how they solve the equation
see how easy it was so all of this is
magic
we don't have a we don't have a
procedure we don't have an explanation
for how that happens what the mechanism
is
they cannot tell you why you know what
caused
the uh neutrino to pop in from the void
and then go back
they don't have an explanation for any
of that and so it's it's magic
essentially they're saying
you know there's this reaction there's
so much energy we cannot account for
we'll call that energy neutrino
what is energy energy is mass that's the
particle part
of their explanation then they turn it
back into energy which is what they
borrowed from
the vacuum this seething energy that's
out there in the background
you know that's that's just magic that's
that's not answering the question that's
like saying you know what came from
before the big bang
they say oh we don't know what came
before the big bang why why do you dare
ask that
question what do you mean you're saying
that all the galaxies are flying apart
you take the movie backwards all the
galaxies are closer and closer together
you take it all the way to 14 billion
years ago and you end up with a
singularity
well obviously you know why don't you
keep going with your rewinding of the
tape go to square one you know to frame
number one what happened to frame number
one they said well we don't know that's
an unscientific question because we have
no way of proving it
we have no way of running an experiment
to find out how matter came into being
from nothing
because space is made of something
anyway so i don't know you know
how did the something come into being
from nothing and they they say it's an
unscientific question
because they can't prove it through an
experiment and this is no different
this is saying you know we don't know
where the neutrino came from it came
from the vacuum
it's a virtual particle it comes in when
we need it
you know magic wand i need i need that
neutrino so they bring you the neutrino
and you say okay now i fixed the problem
where did the neutrino come from well it
came from the vacuum and you're saying
the vacuum is made out of particles
what surrounds each particle what gives
shape to each particle
what is that stuff called more neutrinos
is it the higgs field that's giving
shaped
to the neutrino field are they all
meshed in there are they all
superimposed uh don't they tangle
so yeah they don't have an explanation
for any of this and that's that's the
bottom line
now there's a coral area here you have
um one particle that does
belong inside the neutron and inside the
proton because it keeps the quarks
together and it's known as the gluon
and as you can see on the upper right
there gluon the little g
i've circled it and put a little arrow
there you can see it's got zero mass
and it's got also zero charge okay they
had to make
the glue on chargeless and massless and
the gluoron is that bed spring you see
on the upper right there that's keeping
the three quarts together the two ups
and one down which
means it's a proton okay and the bed
springs there those are the gluons
but it turns out that the gluon has no
mass but when you separate when two
quarks separate
they stretch the gluon and the gluon
turns into a quark
which does have math mass okay so so
when you separate
these gluons somehow the gluon acquires
mass
okay so it's a baseless particle which
turns into mass
i guess by its interaction with a higgs
field
you figure it out okay so that's the
starting point for our neutrino i'm
going to continue on wednesday
uh with our little with our picolino
neutron and yeah it's uh something that
makes you
kind of think whether quantum mechanics
is on the right track
and there's another coral area here and
that's that strength here is they don't
pay attention to quantum mechanics
anymore
all they want to do is solve the
graviton which is what would unite
gravity uh
quantum mechanics with relativity so
they play around with the graviton how
it falls into the black hole and they
look at what happens at the
edge of the black hole and all that kind
of stuff and they don't care about all
this other stuff they don't care about
neutrinos they don't care about
electrons that's where the particle
physicists over there at
slack and lhc and fermilab and all these
other places brookhaven
so they play around with all that stuff
we don't care about that because these
people are into you know vibration of
lines
and they call those gravitons and those
gravitons you know fall into black holes
so they're in a different world
and part of the reason is that uh
quantum mechanics
is at the dead end i wouldn't say it's a
crisis
because it's it's not an issue of crisis
it's an issue of
we've already got all the equations all
of them
or like uh niels bohr said in 1936
uh quantum is a complete theory and he
was wrong because they came
right after that with all this other
stuff but now it's a complete theory
more or less in the sense that what else
are you going to look for
they were trying to answer the issue of
you know of the
beta decays now they've answered it with
a neutrino they've got a solution for
all that they've got the equations there
what else is there and so they keep
measuring at the lhc and so on
they keep measuring to try to get more
accurate values which i'm not sure what
that's going to give us
it's not going to give us a different
theory okay different explanation
that's one issue the other issue is that
they've invented dark matter and what
all these people are into now is dark
matter they say okay forget about the
neutrino and all that that's that's over
and done with
now we're going to work on dark matter
now we got a new uh
uh cottage industry we're going to call
it the dark matter
cottage industry we got to look for that
particle of mass that
you know makes the galaxies rotate the
way they do and so these guys are
working on dark matter
essentially okay i think uh maybe that
was the last uh 2015 was the last prize
they gave out in neutrino
uh metals maybe there there's gonna be
another one down the line i doubt it
because they've got everything they need
on the neutrino now they're gonna work
on dark matter now it's going to be the
dark matter nobel prize
okay that's that's where all the
attention is going into the new
generations
and these other guys are have abandoned
that completely and they're working on
you know string theory on gravitons
falling into black holes
and so that's the world out there that's
what all these mathematicians are
working on
that's what you are paying for